hi I'm Erik Bosse uh I mean Philip
Malina Erik's busy doing The Walking
Dead breakdown in HBO just dropped six
freaking seconds of new Game of Thrones
footage and I was obsessively ranting
about it anyway so we figured let's put
that nerdy panic attack on camera here
we go all right now the bulk of the
footage though again six seconds was
actually sandwiched into the middle of a
preview of all the new stuff HBO has
coming this year but they did open on
what I think is a new shot from this
season we see a murder of crows or a
manslaughter or bravin's flying over
what appears to be the wall a lot of
people said that this is just a repeat
of one of the opening scenes from last
season where bran sends his warg
collective over the wall to spy on the
night Kings army and it gets disrupted
by this [ __ ] Blair but I checked in
this shot definitely isn't part of that
moment so I'm thinking we got a couple
options here either bran is up to his
old tricks either using his Raven war g2
again spy on his future selfs army CR is
brand the night king Theory video for
more on that
or maybe he's sending them to see what's
up over at you swatch by the sea I guess
more accurately what's down I guess this
could also be non war G Ravens maybe
sent by the survivors of Eastwatch with
a message saying ouch and while that one
doesn't make as much sense to me it's
worth acknowledging that there probably
are survivors since the end of the video
shows a quick shot of torment giant
beard and though it's not a new shot it
could be a clue that he somehow made it
out alive the shooting script the last
scenes for now they actually did imply
that they were headed towards some sort
of zigzag stairs that might be on the
portion of the wall that's still
standing
maybe these now moving ahead to the six
seconds of new footage the name of this
video by the way is it all starts here
and while it clearly is about HBO and
all of its programming I think it's also
a clue about when this footage is from
I'm pretty sure everything we've seen so
far all like twelve seconds has been
from literally the opening moments of
season eight which like HBO why don't
you release a full trailer with more
stuff in it is it because of [ __ ]
youtubers who scrutinize the footage
frame by frame and potentially guess
everything that's gonna happen this
season damn you emergency awesome
alright let's take a look
okay so first thing we see in this block
is this shot of the awesome migrant
Caravan full of tourists from Essos
including drogon flying overhead
obviously you can tell by the weather
and fog that there in the north but our
best guest looking around here in the
scene it's actually just outside of
Winterfell in the area known as winter
town real creative of the names there
George this is where all the Winterfell
adjacent stuff happens this is also
where Tyrion gets to know Roz where
those two orphans got to know Theon and
where Brienne got to know stalking now
let's take a closer look at who we're
seeing here the unsullied are marching
alongside some Dothraki bloodrider z-- I
think that's quote over there I'm glad
to see that these groups are still
getting along so well it must be these
fashionable new scarves that they all
got for each other actually it is worth
pointing out that this synchronous
marching means that everyone has fallen
in line under their general dinars these
famous lockstep columns are often
associated with the order and discipline
of the unsullied army rather than that
loose formation of the Dothraki that
they even helped last season by the way
if you wish had been the other way
around and the Dothraki would have come
to be the larger influence in Danny's
army one you must be really into riding
into battle rocking some fierce smokey
eyeliner and two you've probably never
heard of the Battle of qohor actually I
got to tell you this badass story
because it's the definitive Dothraki
versus on solid story and it's one of my
favorites and fictional military history
however I get it if you're not studying
for the AP SOS history exam you might
want to just get back to the trailer
stuff so go ahead and skip to this time
if you don't want to hear this story
good it's good
okay nerds the Battle of cohort this
takes place say 400 years before the
events of Game of Thrones shortly after
the doom of Valyria which was most
likely a string of volcanic eruptions
across the fourteen volcanoes that
surround Valyria the most fierce
warriors and most of their dragons were
completely wiped off the face of the
known world that meant that the rest of
Essos was right for the taking so the
most fierce students left behind were
the Dothraki it was only dragons that
gave them any fear which is why now
they're so taken by Danny's Dragons
centuries later but under the big bad
smoky eye line call of that time called
Teemo the Dothraki sacked and burned
every town they came upon no standing
army could stop them even though the
Dothraki didn't use shields they didn't
hold tight formations they didn't even
wear armor they would still run right
over the heads of the weaker soldiers
like a hot pot of liquid gold their one
killer tactic other than
opening was using their horseback
archers to fire upon your infantry as
they rode in and then they'd fire
another wave of arrows as they swapped
in a second wave of horse riders each
wave sliding in under the other non-stop
brutality and unlike a sweet tooth rocky
braid so when the city of qohor yes
you're hearing that right got word that
the Dothraki were coming their way they
were like well [ __ ] so they built up
their fortress walls they doubled their
city guard they hired two companies of
sell swords including the second sons
which you might recognize as the same
group that this guy's from oh you don't
recognize that guy right because he quit
playing Daario so you could become the
new face of the transporter movies how'd
that work out okay so you actually might
recognize his new face instead this guy
Don Harris so now Cola [ __ ] has a legit
army with their own cavalry pitting
horse against horse two horses enter one
horse leaves winner gets the girl
horse horse they've also got all these
sell swords and finally just because
it'd be weird if they had these random
sell swords and just a bunch of horses
they decided they needed some
normal-looking infantrymen to just fill
the lines so they're like fine
let's buy 3,000 unsullied from a stupor
and then they can just get all chopped
up for us buying time for our real
soldiers to do some actual fighting oh
and 3,000 could sound like a lot but I
forgot to mention Khal temmo was riding
around with a force of 50,000 Dothraki
so yeah
3,000 versus 50,000 kind of like my high
school fighting my college so many
awkward nerds just slapping each other
so the one annoying thing about the
unsullied remember how they like
marching yeah that's all they do they
don't ride horses
probably rubs them raw in a very tender
spot so it was gonna take them a bit
longer to get back to qohor meanwhile
Khal temmo wasn't patient so he just
attacked and was actually super pumped
to see a somewhat formidable force
waiting for him the Calvary and all the
sell swords that was the most legit
looking resistance his group had
encountered since they started on their
pillage people world tour only the hits
and the steps by the end of the opening
first day of battle yeah all of the
cohorts Calvary was dead I'm the cell
swords like the super badass second
son's yeah they all ran off when things
got scary
this is probably what Jorah Mormont is
referring to about the second son's way
back in season 3 second son's have faced
worse odds and won the second son's have
faced worse odds and run
damn Mormont
okay so Khal temmo lets his man take a
well-deserved break take some naps eat
the horses of their enemies you know guy
stuff so they go to sleep and when they
wake up they find a group of three
thousand eunuchs blocking their path
into qohor and you might not find a
eunuch scary but one they've been
through some [ __ ] and two if you turn
the corner and ran into three thousand
eunuchs you probably be like yeah y'all
can have it but Khal temmo ain't scurred
he's still got pretty much 50,000 horse
riders and Dothraki you think a man not
on horseback ain't no man so they charge
right at them the unsullied they just
point their spears and lower their
shields and held the line 18 times the
Dothraki charged in 18 times the
unsullied held the damn line and that
signature move the Dothraki where they
drain arrows on your man as they rode in
and rode out
well the unsullied were so good at being
a tightly held synchronized unit the men
in the front would block the riders and
everyone else would join their shields
over their heads creating a massive
unified shield blocking all the arrows
over those 18 runs the Dothraki lose
12,000 men I'm sure the horses were fine
though
also Khal temmo yeah he did and all his
sons did the new Khal sees that they
lost and orders the Dothraki to do the
same thing Erik Bosse how to do at the
end of eighth grade they cut off the
hair braids and admitted defeat so
that's the story of the Battle of qohor
and why you can actually say that one
badass eunuch is worth almost 20 smokey
eyed horse riders all right back to the
teaser before we move on from the shot
of the unsullied I'm gonna point out
that the spears take a close look they
don't seem to be made from dragonglass
yet even though last we left them they
were mining tons of that to defeat the
army of the Dead call me crazy but my
guess is they made them into a bunch of
dragonglass bullets and grey worm gets
an Uzi also it's not totally clear but
their breastplates may or may not be
covered in leather if not and they're
about to battle in Winterfell
during winter then Sansa would like a
word are they covering this breast rates
another no my lady
you shouldn't maybe that's the real cold
[ __ ] they should indeed pardon me my
lady
do that leather on this and now right
before we see Aria I want you to see the
look on the face of every other major
character when they saw dragon for the
first time these faces are all best
described as just [ __ ] my pants
meanwhile look at Aria she's smiling
everyone found her running away in
terror and she's never been happier this
is what I imagined Sid from Toy Story
looked like when he found his first
lighter to melt toys with but actually
sadist or not this moment is actually a
huge payoff for the Aria in the books
and in the show in a Storm of Swords
Aria dreams of one day seeing great
things like the Titan of Braavos which
she saw a few seasons back sea monsters
which would be amazing and Dragons but
also this excitement on her face is the
payoff to the foreshadowing made all the
way back in season 2 episode 7 in this
fantastic conversation where aria trying
to pass as a lowborn serving girl is
chatting with her master Tywin freakin
Lannister this seems amazing because
it's loaded with super high stakes
layered over a dinner scene of eating
steak or mutton
actually if Tywin finds out who Arya
really is while her mother is holding
his son hostage then best case he'd hold
her hostage it's not just straight-up
kilter meanwhile our is debating killing
Tywin in this very scene every time he
turns his back so while they chat
despite Arya trying to keep her identity
secret she can't help but give off clues
that she's too educated to be lowborn
with the biggest piece of evidence being
her recollection of old non stories of
Harrenhal burning specifically she knows
way too much about Aegon Targaryen
sisters and fellow Dragon Riders Aegon
Targaryen changed the rules Aegon and
his sisters it wasn't just Aegon riding
his dragon it was Rhaenys and Visenya to
correct student of history
Rhaenys rode meraxes señor Vega had a
Valyrian steel sword she called dark
sister she's a heroine of yours I take
it clearly Arya is so obsessed with the
images of these two fierce warrior women
specifically with Sagna Targaryen that
her excitement almost gives away her
secret in fact if you watch the scene
again it probably does give it away
also if you watch the saying again you
might catch something else you might
have missed in the first viewing this
seems to be a moment where Tywin having
given his dinner to Arya is actually
showing to possibly have a soft spot for
a precocious young girl who maybe
reminds him of
daughter and while that may still be
true you're also missing the real reason
he gave her his dinner having just
survived an assassination attempt Tywin
is having Aria eat his food as a test to
see if it's poison not telling her that
is a win-win for him he comes off just
by another way so anyway Aria is clearly
obsessed with dragons and specifically
badass female warrior Dragon Riders so
theory we've seen in the other teasers
that Sansa seems to be giving a good old
welcome to Winterfell ice glare to
Daenerys Targaryen but I'm thinking when
Aria meets the Dragon Queen it'll be a
different story
and considering that Littlefinger taught
Sansa to prepare for all wars in her
mind at all times is this going to cause
a rift between Sansa and Arya and John
kind of feels like it okay but deeper
theory that's more fun to me sure Arya
might like Danny hey nice to meet you
your dragon is near item that's cool but
Arya doesn't like the idea of meeting
this any of reincarnated she wants to be
Visenya and so I asked what if she will
be Aegon the conquerer was definitely
the leader of the pack a mighty king
enemies beware
however Visenya was the badass fighter
listen to this passage from fire and
blood and tell me who it sounds like the
Senya here is telling her brother Aegon
that his Guardsmen ain't [ __ ] even with
your sword black fire in your hands
you're only one man and I can't always
be with you the King pointed out that he
had Guardsmen around him Visenya drew
her sword dark sister and splashed him
across the cheek so quickly the guards
had no time to react your guards are
slow and lazy she said I could have
killed you as easily as I cut you you
require better protection damn Visenya
but also totally sounds like Arya and
seeing as how this exchange led Visenya
to create the Kingsguard and her to lead
them couldn't you see that beam the role
that Arya is destined for royal
protector of the king
maybe Jon Snow who happens to be her
brother just like Visenya and Aegon or
maybe this exchange could happen between
Ari and Daenerys and it's the Queen she
ends up being sworn to protect
I think Arya being Visenya reborn would
be damn perfect except it's too bad she
doesn't have Dragon Lord blood so she
can't ride a dragon but hey maybe she
can like take his face or something okay
pretty closely of course this only works
out if Arya survives Game of Thrones but
I'm gonna go out on a limb and say as
long as she keeps changing and adapting
she's not gonna die it seems that george
RR martin kills characters who refuse to
change if they're too stubborn in the
game off with her head and before we
wrap up
obviously our is
to meet Danny and I told you how I think
that would go but she's about to have so
many reunions first off her and John
well emotionally you pretended to not
get when John and Sansa were reunited
John and I are you were way closer he's
the one that gave her needle and now
they've both gotten really good at
sticking people with the pointy end
that's gonna be so amazing she's also
gonna reunite with another brother who's
probably changed even more than she has
bran though I think that'll go exactly
how it went when he was reunited with
Sansa and the three-eyed raven i don't
know what that means
so were you like always kind of autistic
err
anyway Gendry that's another crazy
reunion back when those two last saw
each other there's definitely some will
they want the energy to it you'd be
milady
and here's something cool if these two
do get together it would be a surprise
payoff to something Robert Baratheon
said way back in season one I have a son
you have a daughter
it might not be the kids he was talking
about but still pretty cool also I just
like the idea of these two falling for
each other because then we'll get to see
Gendry all confused by tree carvings
that say no one loves Gendry of course
instead I'll probably all freaked out by
her just like hot pie was when they
reunited it's like guys just can't deal
with a powerful murderous woman speaking
of people Arya's vowed to murder
she's also bound to reunite with the
Hound and Melisandre joy what a fun
party we have in store it'll be
interesting to see if Arya sticks to her
murder mantra because they clearly have
new priorities now I'll say that there
might be a clue in her costume these
days back when we saw her first arrive
in Winterfell asking to be let in she
was literally wearing rags now she's
dressed in Winterfell - she isn't the
simple assassin she was when she first
got back to Westeros she's now a new
hybrid each Slayers representing a
different time for her she's got the
skirt and lace jerkin with cap shoulders
in the style of Braavos and her first
fighting teacher Syrio Forel above that
she's got her leather vest along with
her pulled back hair very Ned Stark but
then when it comes to the traditional
start Cape she's the only character on
the show to be shown with it formed
asymmetrically she's adapted it to allow
quick access to her sword which most
Westerosi men don't worry about since
they usually enter battle with plenty of
warning this represents her scrappy time
with the faceless men so my point is is
it possible that she's grown past the
need for vengeance well it's fun to
imagine her crossing off all the names
on her list and it does very well for my
OCD it could be her downfall - we know
how George R feels about characters that
stick too close to their plans but what
do you
it's killing people like Cersei more
important than helping the north fight
off the White Walkers let me know in the
comments below also let me know what you
think of my theories of where she's
gonna end up in general there's one that
I've mentioned before that actually has
her becoming queen of Westeros and
married to Jon Snow it sounds crazy
until you find out their love was a big
part of an earlier draft of the books it
was a whole love triangle between them
and Tyrion weird also there are some
shots at the very end of the trailer but
they didn't seem new and know that one
moment is not John Morgan he's just
looking away from the camera no actually
the shot of ice this area might be new
since it's not nearly as dark out as
when he blew up the wall so maybe that's
new let me know what you think about
that too you can hit me up on twitter at
[ __ ] and follow me on instagram at the
old milena follow at new rockstars for
more about Game of Thrones you guys it's
a weeks away like six weeks but still
also we're gonna have a fun new show to
coincide with the premiere but we're
gonna tell you more about that later
anyway this has been fun being back here
hey buddy you told them about my great
they had to know look someday all the
dark secrets about you're gonna come out
about what you've done
where's Gabe